nothing says summer quite like baseball
and childhood nostalgia
and no film better encompasses the two
than the sandlot
the classic film about baseball and
growing up introduced audiences to a
charming group of child actors
what has a cast of this family-friendly
classic been up to the anticipation is
killing us smalls
tom geary was just 11 years old when he
was cast as new kid in town scotty
smalls the new york native's feature
film debut
geery who started acting to deal with
his shyness landed an agent after she
saw him in a local play the sand lot was
one of his first big auditions but he
didn't initially get the part
luckily for giri the other actor didn't
work out so he came back to screen test
again
and he knocked it out of the park giri
followed up his work in the sandlot with
a role in the 1994 family film lassie
and yet another baseball film the last
home run in 1996
however the shy kid eventually blossomed
into an actor who's mostly made a career
out of playing tough men
he appeared in mystic river and played a
fur trapper alongside tom hardy and
leonardo dicaprio in the revenant
though mike vittar made a considerable
impression on young audiences as star
player benny the jet rodriguez
he only made a handful of appearances in
film and tv afterwards
following the sandlot he continued to
display his athletic abilities on film
as luis mendoza and two mighty duck
sequels
but he quit acting in 1997. in the midst
of his acting career vitara started
training in emergency medical services
in the los angeles area eventually
becoming a firefighter in 2002
he was honored the following year for
his work saving two fellow firefighters
during a house fire in the hollywood
hills
unfortunately not all of vitar's actions
have been heroic
he was arrested in 2015 after allegedly
assaulting a grad student on halloween
in northwest los angeles with two other
firefighters
patrick renna stole bases and hearts as
hamilton ham porter with one line
you're killing me smalls he reunited
with sandlot cast mate chauncey lia
party two years later in the soccer
flick the big green
following a turn opposite comedian pauly
shore and son-in-law
renna continued working throughout the
90s appearing on plenty of television
favorites like home improvement
boy meets world the x-files and a string
of movies
more recently he appeared in the
kickstarter funded film bad roomies
which he also co-produced
rena also recently returned to the
screen in a big way with a recurring
guest role in the netflix wrestling
dramedy glow
as a socially awkward superfan cupcake
chauncey leah party made his film debut
in 1991's father of the bride remake
starring steve martin
just 12 years old on the set of the
sandlot leopardy admitted that he would
constantly pester director david mickey
evans
about when they'd be filming his
character's kiss with lifeguard wendy
peppercorn
leah party worked quite a bit after
receiving his poolside cpr
popping up in 90s faves like casper with
christina ricci
who he co-starred with again in the
opposite of sex in 1998
he also played bully allen on the
beloved cult tv show freaks and geeks
bill you want some crushed nuts with
your sundae
leah party also had a recurring role on
gilmore girls
from 2009 to 2012 leopardy made a living
as a professional poker player
but a big loss forced him into the job
market he lives in los angeles with his
daughter and regularly appears at
special fan events and screenings
yeah yeah like more than one of his
sandlot castmates
marty york made his screen debut in the
film which he followed with small parts
on saved by the bell the college years
and a couple episodes of boy meets world
other than sandlot fan events and a 2015
episode of adult swims the eric andre
show
the place he's appeared the most has
been gossip site tmz
which reported he was arrested for
alleged domestic violence in 2009
since his little league days york has
transformed from scrawny kid to buff
personal trainer
and at one point he was working on
developing a line of workout supplements
he dubbed
beast juice a reference sandlot fans
were recognized as being inspired by the
fearsome dog the crew has to face
brandon quentin adams was one of the few
kids in the cast who already had quite a
bit of acting experience prior to
appearing in the sand lot
adams got his start dancing in michael
jackson's 1988 music video for smooth
criminal
he did quite a bit of tv in the late 80s
and made his feature film debut in wes
craven's 1991 horror flick the people
under the stairs
after the success of the sandlot he
appeared again alongside cast mate karen
allen in ghost in the machine
and reunited with mike vitar and d2 the
mighty ducks
after doing some voice over work for the
video game kingdom hearts 2 in the late
2000's
adams pivoted into a hip-hop career
releasing an album called
b lee hd grant gelt got his start with a
string of tv appearances on knott's
landing
tales from the crypt northern exposure
and others making his film debut and the
steven seagal action movie marked for
death
in 1991 however the sandlot gave him the
biggest role of his short acting career
gelt has since started a new chapter in
his career moving from artist management
into a senior executive role at the
artist the fan engagement platform full
screen direct
actor shane obedzinski's on-screen
career was brief
he made his feature film debut in 1991's
my girl starring macaulay culkin
and was cast as little tommy repeat in
the sandlot a couple years later after
an audition in orlando
obedzinski quit acting after the sandlot
and returned to florida to finish school
after graduating he toured for a few
years with a local band before opening
his own pizza parlor in brandon florida
dennis leary was still relatively new to
acting when he appeared in the sand lot
as scotty's small stepfather bill
he'd spent nearly a decade working his
way up the stand-up comedy circuit in
boston and new york
before his one-man show no cure for
cancer catapulted him to fame
leery continued making a name for
himself throughout the 90s and
everything from demolition man to
pixar's a bug's life
he was a regular on the late night
circuit and continued performing
stand-up as well as producing comics
come home
the annual tv special for charity
featuring prominent comedians
leary is perhaps best known for his emmy
nominated performance and writing on the
fx firefighter dramedy rescue me which
ran for seven seasons
he also wrote produced and starred in
the series sex and drugs and rock and
roll for fx
but he still had plenty of other career
home runs thanks to the hbo drama
recounts and appearances in two amazing
spider-man films
i was wrong about you peter
this city needs you
[Music]
here you're gonna need this
he may not have been able to handle a
certain treehouse vacuum cleaner but
victor de matia certainly cleaned up
when it came to booking acting jobs
prior to playing timmy timmons demetea
appeared on tv as dennis the menace
as well as tv shows like family ties and
punky brewster he made his big screen
debut and turner and hooch with tom
hanks
and worked with rapper vanilla ice on
his ill-fated screen debut
cool as ice dimantia quit acting a few
years after the sand lot
and pursued other interests including
playing in a band he works as a
bartender in la
writes comedy and hangs out on occasion
with castmate marty york in addition to
putting in regular appearances at
sandlot fan events
on top of that he also runs a pop
culture centered podcast called vic in a
box
which he launched in mid-2017 with a
commentary segment on being part of the
sandlot
the sandlot cemented marley shelton's
place as an all-time movie dream girl
the minute she appeared on screen in
wendy peppercorn's signature red bathing
suit and white sunglasses
up until that point shelton had mostly
tv credits on her resume
but after the sand lot her career really
took off the california blonde later
appeared in pleasantville and never been
kissed
and wasn't afraid to go grind house for
quentin tarantino in 2007's death proof
she appeared in the stylish sin city and
has worked with oliver stone twice
in 1995's nixon and 2008's w she also
popped up as jones bff on an episode of
mad men in 2013.
most recently she appeared alongside
dwayne the rock johnson in his 2018
video game adaptation rampage
veteran character actor art lefleur had
some pretty legendary cleats to fill
when he accepted the role of the babe in
the sandlot
luckily lefleur already had a couple of
baseball films under his belt
mr baseball and field of dreams making
him something of a sports film mvp
he's worked fairly consistently ever
since appearing in cult classics like
the blob
family fair like the santa claus 2 and
episodes of house and key and peel
by the time karen allen appeared as the
empathetic mom in the sandlot she had
already cemented her place in fans
hearts
as katie in 1978's classic frat comedy
animal house
and indiana jones gal pal marion
ravenwood in 1981's raiders of the lost
ark
indiana jones
always knew someday you'd come walking
back through my door
spunky and likeable allen made for an
affable sparring partner to bill murray
and scrooged
and turned on the waterworks and john
carpenter's sci-fi drama starman
opposite jeff bridges
after her son was born in 1990 allen
took smaller roles such as her work in
the sand lot so she could spend more
time with her family
in 1993 she and her son moved to
massachusetts into a converted barn
she'd purchased
she got involved in the local theater
scene acting in and directing plays at
the berkshire
theatre festival and teaching classes
steven spielberg managed to lure her
back for the fourth indie flick
indiana jones in the kingdom of the
crystal skull in 2008 but alan has
mostly remained happily out of the
spotlight
like his character in the sandlot james
earl jones has his own history with
baseball
at least on screen and in the theater
prior to appearing as the reclusive mr
myrtle
in the 1993 flick jones similarly opened
up about the love of the game in 1989's
field of dreams
appeared alongside richard pryor and
billy d williams in 1976's the bingo
long traveling all-stars and motor kings
and won a tony award in 1987
in august wilson's play fences jones has
also used his golden voice to narrate on
several occasions
including the 1984 documentary there was
always sun shining someplace
beyond his associations with baseball
the distinguished multi-award-winning
actor has been a fixture in film
tv and on stage for decades though it is
his booming baritone
voice that has become his most
recognizable talent from darth vader to
mufasa
jones has become the go-to guy for
voices narration and commercials needing
gravitas
totes my goats